to present the next award from Brazil
one of the world's most glamorous
actresses star of kiss of the Spider
Woman and one of our most versatile and
handsome young actors Academy Award
whoops I knew I wouldn't get this
Academy Award winner for producing One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest miss Dona
Braga and mr. Michael Douglas
watch the Oscars when your Brazil oh yes
yeah it's a popular show very popular
you love it
yeah you should say something to your
friends in Brazil and they stopped me to
sell badges she misses you
I'm very happy Sonia Tomoko contactor
yeah very no sense a presence at any
local attraction and very proud to be
here and tell everybody in Brazil at
Indiana one by one
now the nominees for best achievement of
live-action short films are exiting
Steph Stefano reali and Philip are too
loose lovestruck fredda wise producer
cashless even chat working for dissing
and the winner is precious images Chuck
workman
a year ago the Directors Guild of
America wanted to say thank you to the
American motion picture industry and
this is a hell of a way to say you're
welcome thank you very much thank you to
Bob wise and David Shepherd to a one-man
cheering section in George Sidney to Gil
Cates of the Directors Guild and Michael
Franklin Directors Guild and the 80 300
members of the Directors Guild of
America who stand with me here and thank
you so much for making us precious
images for me
he won last year for Best Actor her kiss
of the Spider Woman
here's nominate again this whoops whoa
excuse me
he's nominated again this year for Best
Actor and for children of a lesser God
and I wonder when he'll be nominated for
next year
me yeah William Hurt
you